lastly I wanted to do a shout out
sitting here today with us as my buddy
Cameron voices dad Victor and his sister
Maya
Cameron boy she was so excited for me
and wanted to be here uh isn't here
today his all too brief appearance in
this life though inspired me beyond
words and many of us here and
generations of kids and families all
over this world his extraordinary talent
and loving heart will be remembered to
his foundation the foundation is called
the Cameron voice foundation and has
been set up by his family to remember
Cameron by continuing his pursuit to
make positive change in the world
Cameron said we can't take it with us so
it's about what you leave and and with
this I promise Cameron that I will carry
this goodness with me in all the days of
my life I gotta say you did bring up
Cameron boys today how do you think the
3rd descendents movie is really gonna
pay tribute well it does everything that
Cameron's in he brings the light every
every room that he walked into every
cause that he that he you know pushed
for and everything that he ever did I
mean he was it was impossible not to be
drawn into him that's how I found him I
fell in love with him when he was doing
Jesse and I went after him for
descendants oh yes oh yes and so
descendants 3 you know again we'll just
remind everybody of his incredible gift
you know he was bioluminescent he was
lit from the inside out he really was
and and we will miss him but we will
carry his legacy forward
what is the future of descendants the
future of descendants is in the hands of
the Walt Disney Company and channel I
hope that will be on their new streaming
service next year and and you know that
they are now making a high school
musical series so you never know there
may be something down the road with with
descendants again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]